hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zur super easy german heute
aus singapur
bei uns sind can can und jessica jessica
und die beiden sind easy german
zuschauer aus singapur
wir stellen euch heute adjektive vor
beziehungsweise die steigerung von
adjektiven das zeigen wir euch jetzt los
geht's als erstes zeigen wir euch die
regelmäßigen adjektive bei den
regelmäßigen adjektiven sind alle
steigerungen gleich hier seht ihr ein
paar beispiele
ich stehe weit weg von der kamera steht
noch weiter weg von der kamera und
jessica steht am weitesten weg von der
kamera
dieses gebäude sieht interessant aus
dieses gebäude sieht noch interessanter
aus dieses gebäude sieht am
interessantesten aus janosch ist dick
janisch ist die khs ist
[Gelächter]
ich gehe schnell geht schneller
jessica geht am schnellsten
dieses blau ist hell dieses blau ist
heller dieses blau ist am hellsten das
wetter in deutschland ist normalerweise
schlecht das wetter in polen ist
manchmal noch schlechter am
schlechtesten
heute das wetter
singapur
jetzt zeigen wir euch einige
unregelmäßige adjektive die
unregelmäßigen adjektive müsst ihr
einfach auswendig lernen
hier sind ein paar beispiele dieses
gebäude ist hoch dieses haus ist höher
dieses gebäude ist am höchsten ist groß
jessica ist größer ich bin am größten
ich bin alt aber dieses gebäude ist
älter und dieses gebäude ist am ältesten
[Musik]
janus trinkt gerne
noch lieber trinkt die amish kaffee
am liebsten trinkt jannis cappuccino ich
tue viel zucker in meinen kaffee jessica
tut mehr zucker in ihrem café
ken loach am meisten zucker in seinem
café das war unser video über die
steigerung von adjektiven im deutschen
jetzt regnet ist und wir trinken kaffee
danke kennen und jessica dass wir dabei
war
und wenn dir noch übungen machen wollt
und selber adjektive steigern möchte
dann werdet unbedingt einen patch in von
in german dann könnt ihr selber ein paar
interaktive übungen machen und alles
ausprobieren
außerdem solltet ihr easy german
abonnieren dann freuen wir uns sehr
liebe grüße aus singapur und bis bald